lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
pensemos acerca de la configuración
electrónica de un átomo cuyos electrones
de mayor energía no se encuentran en el
bloque s o en el bloque p sino en el
bloque de y vamos a trabajar con la
tabla periódica pero la voy a
reorganizar un poco voy a tomar al helio
el cual tiene sentido que esté aquí en
la parte superior derecha porque es un
gas noble sin embargo voy a ponerlo acá
porque su configuración electrónica es1
es2 si yo hago esto nos permitirá
construir un bloque ese y esto quiere
decir que con algunas excepciones algún
elemento que se encuentre en este bloque
su electrón de mayor energía estará en
una sub capa s así que este es el bloque
s por ejemplo los electrones de más
energía en el potasio estarán en la sub
capa 4 s mientras que los electrones de
mayor energía del hidrógeno por supuesto
que se encontrarán en la sub capa 1 s
pero estará en una sub capa s y esto
ahora nos permite dividir la tabla
periódica en otros bloques este d
es el bloque p el mismo concepto la
regla general dice que los electrones de
mayor energía en la configuración
electrónica de estos elementos estarán
en una sub capa p este es el bloque p de
aquí y como pudieron haber adivinado
este de aquí en medio es el bloque de y
hablaremos más adelante del bloque f que
de hecho lo pueden poner aquí y empujar
los bloques de ip para hacerle espacio
pero eso lo haremos en otro vídeo así
que este de aquí es el bloque de porque
esto nos es de ayuda bueno si algo se
encuentra en el bloque de podemos decir
que esos electrones de mayor energía y
bueno van a ver unos casos especiales
pero podemos decir que en general los
electrones de mayor energía se
encontrarán en una sub capaz de por
ejemplo si nos enfocamos en el hierro su
electrón de mayor energía estará en una
sub capaz de ahora la sub capas de se
vuelven interesantes por ejemplo para
los sub capas es
y podemos vernos el oxígeno y vemos que
el oxígeno se encuentra en el bloque p
así que sus electrones de mayor energía
se encontrarán en una sub capapé y
podemos ver a su periodo y veremos que
está en la sub capa 2 p incluso podemos
ver que en su configuración electrónica
va a ser 1 s 2 2 s 2 y 1 2 3 4 2 p 4
como sé que es 2 p porque me encuentro
en el segundo periodo 2 p o podríamos
decir que es el segundo renglón aquí en
la tabla periódica 1 s 2 2 s 2 y 2 p 4
ahora podrían verse tentados al ver esta
tabla y hacer la configuración de un
elemento como el hierro decimos bueno
tenemos este 4 ese 2 y podrían verse
tentados a decir ah pues es el 4 de 64
de 24 de 3 4 de 4 etcétera pero en la
sub capa de de hecho nos tenemos que
regresar a llenar la tercera capa aquí
lo que tenemos que recordar es que si
queremos saber cuál es la sub capa que
debemos llenar digamos
para el hierro y si decimos bueno el
hierro está en el cuarto periodo pero
cuando trabajamos con la sub capaz de
debemos restarle un uno a ese periodo
por lo que sus electrones de mayor
energía no se encontrarán en la sub capa
4d sino en la sub capa 3d pero hagamos
esto un poquito más concreto al
encontrar toda su configuración
electrónica así que esto de aquí es
hierro tenemos 1s 2 2 s 2 nos vamos a
llenar el bloque t y llegamos hasta la
configuración electrónica del neón que
son 1 2 3 4 5 6 en el bloque p así que
es 2 p 6 y ahora pasamos a la tercera
capa de nuevo tenemos 3 s 2 y ahora
vamos a llenar la sub capa p de la
tercera capa por lo que será 3 p 6 que
es la configuración electrónica del
argón 3 p 6 pasamos a 4s 2
y ahora vamos a llenar no la sub capa 4
d sino la sub capaz de desde recordamos
que en el bloque d tomamos el periodo y
le restamos 1 estamos en el cuarto
período pero le vamos a restar un 1 a
este así que la regla general es ver
esto como 3 de 13 de 23 de 33 de 4 3 de
5 3 de 6 así que es 3 de 6 y esta es la
configuración electrónica del hierro
llegamos a la sub capa de y esto es algo
bastante interesante ya que cuando
pensamos en los electrones que se
encuentran más alejados del núcleo los
que están más alejados del núcleo se
encuentran en la capa 4 son estos de acá
pero si pensamos en los electrones que
tienen más energía son los que se
encuentran en tres de seis pero llenan
una capa anterior una forma de verlo es
que si recordamos estas como formas
tridimensionales de los modelos de cómo
lucen los orbitales las funciones de
distribución de probabilidad que siguen
los electrones dependiendo de cuál sea
su estado de energía uno
de verlo es que estos electrones de
mayor energía comienzan a llenar la
brecha de una función de distribución de
probabilidad en tres dimensiones en la
capa en la tercera capa así que los
electrones que se encuentran más
alejados están en esta sub capa 4s pero
los que tienen más energía se encuentran
en la su capa 3d